good afternoon today we're going to
continue looking at the interaction of
viruses with hosts we're going to talk
about these kinds of the different kinds
of interactions that can occur we're
gonna start talking about virulence
viral virulence this means the capacity
of a virus to cause disease in the
infected host viral virulence so we say
a virulent virus causes significant
disease while one it is a virulent or
attenuated causes reduced or no disease
so as you can see by the definition that
it's going to be a relative term
we can measure virulence there are a
variety of ways to measure it this is
just some of them you could measure the
mean time to death if you're infecting
an experimental animal with a virus you
can measure the mean time to symptoms a
specific symptom caused by the virus you
can measure fever the induction of fever
weight loss is very typical or the
measurement of lesions caused by the
virus so poliovirus if you inject it
into a an animal will cause destruction
of motor neurons and you can see these
lesions in the brain and spinal cord so
a very well trained pathologist can
quantify those HIV infection causes a
reduction in the cd4 positive
lymphocytes in the blood you can measure
that you can draw blood and count the
cd4 positive lymphocytes yeah
well you can't give people viruses right
you can only observe what a virus does
you can't manipulate it the key to
studying virulence is to change the
virus and see what happens you can't do
that in people so you always have to
make correlations you can see one season
influenza virus kills more people than
another and but you're always yeah
that's a natural but there you cannot
often make conclusions from that so it's
very difficult to do what you can do is
observe what happens so we know that HIV
is is virulent because it does this to
cd4 positive lymphocytes but you always
have to make correlations with an animal
model which is never perfect because
that's why it's a model so it's very
difficult but though in the long term
you can draw some conclusions obviously
so here is a two examples of measuring
virulence of viruses on the left is a
graph of the number of survivors after
infecting mice with two different
strains of poliovirus
so you can see type 1 strain the mice
are all living up to 15 days type 2
strain the mice are all dead by 15 days
so that's a very crude measure of
virulence so you could say that this
virus is more virulent than the blue one
on the right the multiplication of
different viruses in the central nervous
system of of an experimental animal and
here we're measuring the lesions in this
in the central nervous system so someone
is looking at sections in a microscope
and putting a number on the lesions and
you can see in 3 different parts of the
CNS the cerebrum brain stem and spinal
cord for five different viruses you have
different numbers of lesions very few
lesions with dengue a lot of lesions
with Japanese encephalitis virus and
some of them fall in between so just a
measure of the wait another way to
measure virulence it's very important to
remember that virulence is a relative
property it's very difficult to compare
the virulence of HIV and polio because
they use different experimental animals
in different measurements for the
virulence
so you can't really do that variance is
influenced by dose route of infection
species of the animal age gender
susceptibility and many many other
things as well so unless you're
measuring the virulence of two viruses
exactly the same way
you really cannot compare the virulence
of those two so for similar viruses we
could take two different polio viruses
like we did in that experiment and put
them in animals the same way and you can
compare the virulence but you can't do
it if you have any aspect of the assay
that is different here's an example of
how just the root of inoculation in an
animal will change the virulence of the
virus so on the Left we have a curve of
a virus multiplication pfu per
milliliter and with days after infection
so these are suckling mice given virus
subcutaneously right under the skin to
different viruses lacrosse and Tonya and
these are and then we're measuring the
amount of virus in the brain here in the
solid circles and the viremia in the
blue in the lighter blue line
so that's lacrosse brain viremic if I
read me of course virus in the blood and
then titania viremia and brain by this
root apparently doesn't multiply in the
brain and doesn't cause a very Mia but
if you inoculate these mice interest
cerebrally put a needle right in the
brain can do that mice are pretty
resilient you see the amount of virus in
the brain of lacrosse here and Tonya
does very well when you put it right in
the brain and you would also say from
this of course that Tonya is not very
neuro invasive right because we're
putting it at a peripheral site and it
doesn't seem to be getting into the
brain so the root of inoculation can
make a big difference so you certainly
have to have the same root to compare
virulence here's another example of this
The effect of inoculation of virulence
we have two different lacrosse viruses
so that's the same one here from La
Crosse Wisconsin
anybody from Wisconsin here know every
state has an advisor wild type virus
suckling mice versus adult might
interest cerebral versus subcutaneous in
suckling mice the amount of viruses
needed to kill fifty percent of the
animal one virion will kill fifty
percent of the animals here same with
adult IC but then subcutaneously you
need you need ten times more and this is
very telling this is an attenuated
mutant so attenuated means it has
reduced virulence it's probably was it
was engineered or selected in some way
to make it attenuated one for IC and
suckling mice over a hundred thousand
pfu subcutaneously and then over a
million in over ten million in adult
mice so two different viruses two very
different patterns of virulence
depending on the route of inoculation so
what we try and do in virology one of
the things we try and do is to identify
what makes viruses virulent we want to
know the viral genes that are involved
and the host genes and we usually do
this by mutation below there are other
ways nowadays and originally it was only
possible to do so by mutation you delete
a gene or you disrupt the gene that you
think is involved in virulence and you
see the effect in an animal if you have
reduced virulence you say this gene is
involved in virulence and then you have
to figure out how you have to look at
the mechanism of that so here's an
experiment where we're trying to
identify some virulence genes with which
illustrates what I'm talking about we
have a virus a wild type virus that
grows very well in cell culture and when
you inoculate this into the brain of
mice the virus multiplies in the brain
and it's neuro virulent it causes some
neurological disease so we say this
virus is neuro virulent we now introduce
a mutation into this virus and that
mutation impairs the replication of the
virus and cells is shown here by fewer
plaques so in cell culture doesn't grow
well you put it in the brain of the
mouse it also doesn't grow well in the
brain and it's attenuated which means it
has reduced virulence
now this is not a particularly
interesting mutation because all you've
done is make the virus less fit
basically and so if there's nothing
specific about that mutation but look at
the next one we make a mutation in
another gene and this mutation does not
markedly affect replication and cell
culture but when you put it in the
animal it is still it is attenuated it
doesn't replicate well in the animal
it's attenuated has less virulence so
this is an interesting gene this is
something that you specifically need to
cause disease or to be very limited in
animal as opposed to a gene that you
need for replication in general and so
those are the kinds of genes that are of
interest to people studying viral
virilis so that's how you would identify
such a gene and then you figure out what
it's doing so this has been done for
many viruses over the years mutation
infect animals and the consequence is
you could put all the viral genes that
affect virulence into four different
classes all right there are those that
affect the ability of virus to replicate
which we've talked about which I don't
find particularly interesting there are
those that modify the host defense
mechanisms that's that's very
interesting so it's a gene product the
virus that the virus uses to somehow
modify the immune response of course in
cell culture there is no immune response
there's an innate immune response but
not an adaptive one so this is not going
to tell you much in cell culture but in
an animal it will and then there are
genes that allow spread of the virus and
the host so those are very interesting
and again in in cell culture you
wouldn't necessarily pick these up and
then there are some that have cell
killing effects these could be of these
could have an effect in cells in in the
animal but not likely to affect the
amount of virus produced in cell culture
so these could also be interesting as
well that's my particular bias on the
interest of these mutations if you talk
to ten other virologists you might get
ten other views as well but since I'm
teaching this course you can listen to
my view
okay here's an example of even
non-coding sequences can have an effect
on virulence so so far I'm talking about
mutating a gene coding for something and
a protein and having an effect on
virilis but even non-coding regions can
have an effect this is an example of a
mutation in a vaccine strain of
poliovirus so we have two different
kinds of polio vaccine strains there is
one that is inactivated it's a
non-infectious vaccine and then there's
a second which is an attenuated a live
attenuated vaccine and these have
mutations in their five prime non-coding
regions that make them attenuated
another example is also within the five
prime non-coding region of another
picornavirus called mango virus there's
a poly c track there that if you delete
it they that reduces virulence in mice
so you don't have to make a protein to
influence virulence a non-coding region
of a virus can also have effects on
virulence this is to illustrate the
non-coding mutations in the Sabin
vaccine strains and we'll come back to
these later this is a very interesting
story if you remember the five prime
non-coding region of corner viruses has
this highly structured region it's
called an iris and that's involved in
translation you see there all these
stem-loop structures in the iris and
this one here stem-loop six it's blown
up here on the right you can see these
numbers in red these are the mute there
are three serotypes of polio and the
vaccine has three serotypes in it and
each has a slightly different mutation
in the 5-prime non-coding region that
makes it a good vaccine makes it not
give you polio most of the time anyway
so this type one it has a change here I
don't know why this is G to G this
should be GTA this is secede so that's
the type one strain of G to a and I've
shown this for 15 years and I've never
noticed this was think before and
there's a change at this position
from a G to an A and a type 2 strain and
then in the type 3 strain there's a
change from a C to a you so single base
changes in each of the strains make them
not able to cause paralysis we'll talk
about how that works another time now
you can show this effect in mice this is
actually an experiment from my lab from
1983 my first graduate student he took
he made two different polio viruses and
one of them had a C at position 472 and
if you look back at this side the the
parental wild-type polio sequence here
is C this is this is a virulent virus
and the vaccine has a u so he made two
viruses that were exactly the same
except for either a C or a you at 472
and he injected these into mice and you
can see the C virus and rad grows pretty
nicely this is growth in the brain at
times after infection and the virus with
EU doesn't replicate it slowly cleared
and the the virus with you is not
virulent at all we're looking at the the
50% lethal dose the amount of virus
needed to kill half of the animals we
don't reach any endpoint more than 10
million pfu whereas the virus with a C
is markedly more virulent okay 9000 pfu
will kill half the animals whereas the
other one we don't kill half even if we
put 10,000,000 pfu is which is as much
as we can put in so a single base change
in a non-coding region can have this
effect so examples of genes that modify
host defense mechanisms you'll hear more
from Professor silverstein about these
some of them are called viral kinds
these are viral homologues of cytokines
they are secreted proteins that mimics
cytokines member cytokines are produced
during the early immune responses to
virus infection and these are viral
encoded proteins that mimic those
cytokines and there's also another class
called of i receptors and these are
virus encoded proteins that mimic the
receptors for cytokines and other immune
molecules so you see they're antagonists
the viral kinds will bind to the normal
receptor for the cytokine on the host
cell and block its active
so these impaired the immune response
they mimic normal cellular molecules and
they basically sabotage the innate and
adaptive defenses but they're not needed
for growth and cell culture so this is
an example of that class of genes that
you pick up in the animal has no effect
on growth and cell culture but has a
market effect on virulence so this is
these if you take away these viral kinds
of virus receptors from the viruses
they're much less virulent than an
animal because they can't overcome the
host defense most of these have been
found in the big DNA viruses big DNA
genomes that is and these are the
functions the soluble cytokine receptors
they bind cytokines and then they're
also proteins that bind key
intermediates in the complement cascade
you remember the complement cascade is a
series of proteins which undergo
activation when an antibody binds a
foreign substance and a lot of the
components of complement are in fact
antagonized by specific viral gene
parameters they're also ones that affect
antigen presentation which I believe you
will hear more about from Professor
silverstein so here's an example of one
of these proteins this is an experiment
where we take a gamma herpes virus 68
one of its genes called m3 it encodes a
chemokine receptor so this is a soluble
protein that floats around and binds up
all the chemokines that are produced by
the immune cells when they're responding
to this virus so they can't work they
you know chemokines main role is to
attract cells into the infected area
lymphocytes and macrophages well the
virus makes a chemokine receptor that
binds those so they can't work it's a
great antagonist so here you see on the
left the percent survival of of animals
with increasing doses of virus we have
wild type virus and blue here so you get
a certain dose response and then if you
delete the m3 gene which encodes this
chemokine receptor you see it's less
virulent you need more virus to kill the
same number of mice so
you can see by comparing the curves how
it's been attenuated by deletion of that
gene now if you restore the gene here
it's called mr marker rescue which is
restoring the gene to the deleted virus
it now returns its virulence to that of
wild-type so that shows you that you
haven't changed anything else in the
genome except delete the m3 gene so it
has an effect on virulence and the right
we have measured the amount the number
of different cells that are coming in to
a particular infected area of the animal
so you can look at macrophages
neutrophils lymphocytes monocytes you
can do this by flow cytometry or some
other staining method and you can see
that in blue is the pattern for the wild
type virus say so let's look at
macrophages so you get a certain number
of macrophages coming in but if you take
away the m3 gene you get more
macrophages coming in it's telling you
that the chemokine that m3 is
antagonizing is now taken away so the
chemokine is working to bring more
macrophages into the infected area other
genes that are involved in virulence are
those that enable the virus to spread
within the host I'm going to give you
two examples of this real virus if you
inoculate intramuscularly in mice it
spreads to the central nervous system
via the blood okay
I am inoculation intramuscular it gets
in the blood gets into the CNS if you do
the same experiment with type three real
virus it spreads via the nerves not via
the blood okay the gene that encodes the
outer capsid protein which is Sigma one
determines the route of spread because
you can reassert thank you we can
reassert the gene among the different
viruses and show that that is what
controls the route of spread and this
recognized this is the gene product that
recognizes the cell receptor another
example is herpes simplex virus type one
a single amino acid change in one of the
glycoproteins in the envelope of the
virus called G D blocks the ability of
the virus to spread to the central
nervous system after inoculation in the
footpad so wild type virus you put it in
the footpad gets into the CN
just one amino acid change in GD will
block that two examples of genes that
enable virus spread unfortunately we
don't know the mechanisms by which these
are involved in spread remember I told
you
uou start by identifying genes that are
involved in virulence but really you
need to know how they work
so for these two cases we don't know how
they're working very few viruses encode
toxic proteins bacteria do this all the
time enterotoxins for example produced
by enterotoxigenic e.coli and a variety
of other bacteria secreted proteins that
have toxic effect very rare in viruses
there is one example the road of viruses
those are double-stranded RNA viruses
that cause gastroenteritis they encode a
protein called NS p4 it's the little red
triangles here and this is really a
toxin it's an enterotoxin it is produced
in infected cells and secreted above and
below the mono layer so this is a
epithelial layer in the intestine which
is where these viruses infect see the
very nice lined up epithelial cells here
they're being infected by rotaviruses
and they're producing NS p4 and this has
a variety of effects that the outcome of
course of this infection is
gastroenteritis diarrhea so diarrhea is
fluid in balance in the intestine and
this protein alone if you make this
protein and feed it to animals they get
diarrhea in the absence of virus
infection so this protein has effects on
its own to cause fluid imbalance and
some of the mechanisms are shown here we
think that one of the things n sp4 does
is to disrupt the tight junctions
between these cells and that allows
water to come out into the intestine
that's a component of the diarrhea of
course we also think that this protein
binds to a receptor on the cell surface
of the epithelial cells and starts a
signaling cascade that results in
increased intracellular calcium and that
in turn forces chloride out of the cells
and then once you do that you get a
chloride imbalance and I don't that
further worsens the diarrhea so that's
the second mechanism and then finally we
think n sp4 goes
below the basement membrane and
interacts with the enteric nervous
system there's a whole network of nerves
innervating your gut and we think that
if this protein interacts with that
system in a certain way it can influence
the fluid imbalance in the intestine so
that's an example of a toxic viral
protein another example of a gene now
this is a cellular gene that's involved
in virulence so far we've been talking
about viral genes this is a cell protein
called trim5 alpha now this is a very
interesting story it began with the
observation that old-world monkeys are
resistant to infection with HIV one and
it turns out that the block to infection
is after entry but before reverse
transcription remember retroviruses from
which HIV is one enter cells and then
they reverse transcribe their RNA into a
DNA copy there's a block in monkeys old
world monkey cells before reverse
transcription this block is mediated by
trim5 alpha cellular protein that
somehow acts on the viral capsid it
recognizes the viral capsid of HIV 1 and
somehow targets it to be degraded so it
never can replicate so if you take away
trim5 alpha in old-world monkeys or
monkey cells HIV 1 will replicate so
that's an example of a cellular protein
that can influence virulence so you may
be asking do we have trim5 alpha or
maybe you're not interested is that a
good question yeah we do but it doesn't
work to prevent HIV infection obviously
yeah so we're not sure why but obviously
there was some other other evolutionary
pressure on our trim5 alpha that changed
it so that it no longer functions to
block infection you only need one or two
amino acid changes to make it not
effective microRNAs I'm sorry yes listen
and people put old wore old world monkey
trim5 into people you can put it into
human cells and it makes them resistant
to infection yes but you can't really
put it into people so we have to have
something else we have to figure out
exactly how trim5 works and then try and
mimic that mimic that with a small
molecule no yeah quite a bit listen to
twit 1:22 we interviewed the guy who
discovered that and he tells the story
of its discovery and and how what kind
of research is going on now microRNAs
are also involved in viral virulence and
I've told you already about Mir 1:22
it's a liver specific micro RNA that
Pepsi requires for replication and if
you give chimpanzees and anti Mir 1:22
you can make small RNAs that will bind
the micro RNA and block their activity
if you give that to chimps they are make
less Hep C when they're infected so this
is actually this is called an int agony
it's actually gonna go into clinical
trials and people to see if it would be
useful to treat Hep C but so micro RNAs
can be very less determinants as well
okay so that's virulence and some of the
ways that we're studying in and how we
think its regulated it's by no means an
exhaustive view now I want to talk a
little bit about how cells how viruses
are virulent so virulence results from
damage in the host and we're going to
talk about the viral side viruses
damaged tissues but also the host
damages itself as well so mechanisms of
cell injury remember when we infect
cells with viruses they caused
cytopathic effects so we presume that
similar things happen in the infected
animal so a cytolytic virus causes
cytopathic effects and this is a bit of
a mystery why this happens we're not
exactly sure for most viruses but many
viruses inhibit a variety of hosts
synthetic processes like RNA synthesis
protein synthesis and this really wreaks
havoc on membrane
enzymes get released from their nice
containers the lysosomes the cytoplasm
is chewed up so we we suspect we
understand what causes cytopathic
effects and it's all viral induced a lot
of envelope viruses you remember cause
fusion of neighboring infected cells so
you get these giant cells with multiple
nuclei they're called since Esha and we
talked about that before so this is
another mechanism of causing cell damage
and virus infection also induces
programmed cell death apoptosis so these
are just some ways that we think viruses
destroy cells both in culture and in the
animal but not all viruses kill cells in
fact many viruses you can infect cells
in culture the cells look just great and
they produce lots of virus for long
periods of time without being destroyed
so how do those viruses cause disease in
an animal well the answer is
immunopathology too much of a good thing
so many of the clinical symptoms of a
virus disease the nonspecific klimt
Amissah symptoms fever tissue damage
aches pains nausea or a consequence of
the host response remember inflammation
last time wrote rube rube or dole or
kale or two more the four classic signs
of inflammation those are caused by the
production of cytokines and we think
that for the viruses that don't kill
cells the immune response is usually
what's causing disease in you so let's
look at some examples of this here's a
list of viruses and what we believe to
be the various immune mediated
mechanisms by which these viruses cause
disease in a host why these viruses are
virulent and you can see some of them
have cd8 positive T cell mediated
mechanisms cd4 positive T cells both th1
and th2 and antibody so basically almost
every arm of the adaptive response has
been implicated in immunopathology so
again what we're saying here is that
these viruses cause damn
to the host via these specific mechanism
so we're gonna look at some of these in
detail now so here's an experiment that
you can do to show that cd8 positive T
cells the cytotoxic T cells that are
important for clearing and infection
they license ected cells that they cause
lethality in some cases so here you've
infected a mouse with an arena virus
lymphocytic Coryell meningitis virus say
the virus of rodents usually doesn't
infect people unless you have a rodent
and you get it from your rodent and if
you happen to be immunosuppressed and
you're you can be in big trouble also
but usually benign to people you infect
rodents though and within a week or so
they're dead
lethal Koryo meningitis okay now you
immune suppress the mice after infection
mice are fine they get a persistent
infection that is they have virus for
the rest of their life but they're okay
so just by suppressing the immune
response with with chemical inhibitors
you can keep them healthy you don't stop
virus replication but they're fine so
this tells you that the immune responses
seems to be part of the lethality now if
you give them what we call adoptive
immunization you give them t-cells from
an infected Mouse so you can infect
another Mouse and take out the t-cells
after a certain period of time transfer
them to this Mouse he dies so the
t-cells in fact specifically the cd8
positive T cells are what's responsible
you can purify various subsets of T
cells and put each one in and show which
one is causing the lethality so that's
an example of immunopathology let's go
on and talk about more of these cd8
positive T cell associated
immunopathology x' this one is
myocarditis inflammation of the heart
caused by another picure no virus
coxsackievirus B it's a very important
infection and in fact a lot of people
who at some point in their lives
suddenly have heart failure and require
a heart transplant it's a consequence of
infection by this virus it's very hard
to detect early on so but
time you do it's for the symptoms and
it's too late to do anything
this virus doesn't kill myocytes
cardiomyocytes it's non-sinusoidal so we
believe that the pathology is occurring
only in immunocompetent animals
immunopathology
and the hypothesis is that cd8 positive
T cells are hurting the cardiomyocytes
they're trying to clear virus infection
but in doing so they're destroying the
heart cells and that leads to heart
failure and in support of that if you
make knockout mice that lack the gene
encoding perforin remember perforin and
granzymes are two genes or proteins that
are important for CTL mediated cell
killing if you make mice that lack
perforin and then you infect them with
coxsackievirus b they get less severe
disease shows you that the perforin
which is a component of cd8 positive
CTLs are important for development of
disease we also think that these cells
probably we also release site cytokines
that recruit inflammatory proteins which
in turn make more cytokines and that
probably contributes to the damage as
well so it's not just perforin but
probably perforin plus other things
released by this cd8 cells and in
support of that one of the chemokines
made by these cells nipple and alpha you
can also take the gene out of mice that
encodes that protein and also these mice
also do not develop myocarditis so this
is interesting because it suggests that
if we could detect infection in people
very early you could perhaps inhibit
this CTL mediated lysis and prevent
heart failure problem is we don't we
don't know how to detect early and that
would involve screening everyone which
at this point is probably not
cost-effective but as i said and when
you know one day you're going to get up
and stand in front of your mirror and
it's going to tell you if you've got any
virus infections but we're not quite
there yet
alright so this is an experiment to show
you what I've just told you these are
two sections of the heart of mice that
have been infected with Coxsackie virus
B let's turn the light off here
now I why don't I tell you that there's
these have been stained with with a dye
called Mason's trichome which stains
blue when the heart is damaged by
myocarditis so when you infect mice with
Coxsackie virus the virus destroys
hearts that well the CTLs destroy heart
cells you get a calcification which is
stained blue by the Masons trichome so
on this slide there's wild-type mice and
knock perforin knockout mice which do
you think is the wild-type mouse switch
1b do you think that's the wild-type
mouse okay this is this is that this is
the wild-type mice in a it has more
pathology it has more calcifications get
more staining this blue stuff here is
the staining
it's the calcification caused by damage
to the myocytes so this is a / 4 +
knockout where there's very little
damage you can see so these mice don't
develop myocarditis okay another example
is liver damage caused by hepatitis B
virus remember that funny virus with the
gapped
DNA genome with a piece of RNA and a
protein on it that has a reverse
transcriptase if you express the
glycoprotein the envelope glycoprotein
of this virus in mice you make a
transgenic Mouse encoding this gene
there's no problem the mice are fine but
if you give these mice virus specific
CTLs which you get from another infected
animal
so you'd adoptive lis transfer those
CTLs into these mice now you get liver
lesions so those CTLs are killing liver
cells because they're expressing the
viral envelope glycoprotein of course
so normally transgenic mice notice this
protein from birth so they're tolerant
to it but if you put in CTL s that
recognize it from another Mouse it will
cause liver damage so it shows you that
in principle liver damage can be caused
by CTLs just like hope myocarditis can
be caused by coxsackievirus infection
so the way this works is that the CTLs
that you inject they attach to
hepatocytes and they induce apoptosis
remember I told you CTLs can not only
lyse target cells but they can induce
apoptosis so that's what's going on here
in addition the the CTL is reduce
release cytokines these recruit other
cells into the area and those enhance
the cell death if you will better pata
site this so if you give these animals
anti interferon gamma antibody it
prevents cell killing so that tells you
that this is a major player it's
probably being released by the CTL x'
and recruiting a lot of cells into the
area that are causing liver damage in
addition if you deplete macrophages from
these mice you also prevent death so the
macrophages are also playing a role here
how about lesions associated with cd4
cells the helper cells okay they'll move
away from the cd8 s-- these of course
make a lot of cytokines remember they
make cytokines needed for b-cell
maturation they make cytokines needed
for CTL maturation so they can have a
lot broader effects than cd8 cells and
they can recruit neutrophils and montaa
clear cells these condemned a magician's
as well as can see TLS so you can see
the cd4 s can be involved in
immunopathology as well they release
these cytokines that recruit cells and
they also can release proteases reactive
radicals peroxy nitrate remember and
also other cytokines like TNF alpha
which can cause a lot of problems so
let's look at an example of that we
actually have examples of
immunopathology that involves both
subsets of cd4 positive T cells th1 and
th2 here's an example of th one now
remember the th one T cells are involved
in maturation of the cytotoxic T
lymphocytes tyler's virus is a
picornavirus that infects mice it causes
demyelination goes to the central
nervous system and results in the
dissolution of the myelin sheath that
surrounds nerves now people don't
understand
this happens because the virus doesn't
replicate in this area but somehow it's
causing demyelination what we think is
going on is that the cd4 positive th1
cells are activating monocytic
phagocytes so they're releasing
cytokines that act that recruit and
activate phagocytes and those then
demyelinating neurons the the monocytic
phagocytes they probably release
superoxide and nitric oxide radicals we
talked about that last time among other
things and these damage the myelin
sheath in addition probably another
cytokine TNF beta produced by the cd4
cells is probably also destroying
oligodendrocytes and these are the cells
that make myelin so a two-pronged attack
on demyelination this is not the viruses
doing remember this is the immune
response against infection that's
causing this problem now when you get an
infection and you have a rash of some
kind in the old days before immunization
we had lots of childhood rashes but not
anymore but these are when they do occur
they're delayed type there's what we
call delayed type hypersensitivity which
means they are caused by t-cells coming
to the area of infection so the each
little pox or rash is an area of
infection and the t-cells are coming to
try and clear the infections in a rash
results many viruses do that measles
smallpox the varicella-zoster and many
others cause rashes all over the body
and these are DTH reactions and this
happens so you have an infection in that
focus and th1 cells and macrophages come
in they're recruited to the infected
area remember by all the cytokines that
are produced and they cause the rash
these cells make other cytokines as well
which further brings in cells and these
increase the permeability of capillaries
in the region and all the cytokines and
chemokines end up bringing in t-cells so
you increase the permeability of a
capillary that lets the lymphocytes
cross the capillary and get into the
infected area and then the chemokines
recruit the t-cells there so that's what
the rash is the t-cells coming in
recruited by all this cytokine activity
so it's called a delayed type
hypersensitivity reaction anybody have
ever had a tuberculous skin test yeah so
you know you get a little stick with it
some to tuberculosis antigen here and if
you have already been infected with
tuberculosis then you have a very rapid
immune response which involves
recruitment of t-cells and the little
bump and redness that you get is a
delayed type hypersensitivity reaction
t-cells coming in okay so once my
daughter had an allergy test where they
put 12 pricks into your skin with
different allergens and you can just
watch the redness growing and I said to
my daughter those are t-cells coming in
there all right this is corneal
inflammation caused by a herpes virus
it's called herpes stromal keratitis one
of the most common causes of blindness
in developed countries and it is
probably entirely immuno pathological
caused by cd4 positive th1 cells so
here's an example of herpes stromal
keratitis you see this clouding of the
cornea so you can't see any longer
repeated infections cause opacity and
reduced vision so what happens here
here's a cross section of cornea so it's
a relatively thin tissue of course now
you have an epithelial layer at the top
which is the darker staining layer you
can see it better in this higher
magnification and then the stromal cells
below it constitute the bulk of the
cornea so what happens is the virus you
get infected with herpes or if you have
a reactivation it infects the corneal
epithelium these cells up here does not
infect the stromal layers below but what
you get is inflammation of C
for positive th1 cells largely to the
stroma so you can see all these darker
staining cells here these are cd4
positive T lymphocytes that are coming
in but these cells are not infected so
presumably they are recruited there by
cytokines produced by the infected cells
by the time these cd4 positive cells are
attacking the virus infection has
actually stopped so you can see this is
sort of a late problem of the immune
response and these get damaged
eventually these stromal cells by the
cytokines that are produced in that
recruit in the cd4 positive T h1 cells
which also produce more cytokines so you
get a lot of cell damage within this
stromal layer and that causes the
opacity and the blindness so this is a
immunopathology cool reaction the virus
isn't even replicating here but the
cells that come in to try and clear the
infection up here damage the cornea
yeah dr. Silverstein
so this comes this can come from another
person what about if you have a lesion
you could you could infect your eye by
yeah yeah okay so next time you have a
fever sore don't be putting your finger
in your eye that's that that's the
lesson because this is a problem in
developed countries that's us right okay
immuno pathological cd4 positive th2
cells the other subset remember these
help B cells mature respiratory
syncytial virus a really important virus
of newborn children the first few months
of age this targets them this have
caused a severe lower tract disease
there's not a cytolytic virus so the
disease is largely immuno pathological
now if you do an experiment you
immunosuppressed mice you get lower
severity lesions caused by the virus
again
the immune responses of our but if you
involve but if you transfer virus
specific cd4 positive th2 cells into
those mice you get worse disease so
these are the cells that are involved
now the in these mice when you transfer
these T cells these th two cells you get
lesions with eosinophils it's thought
that these are recruited by cytokines
that are produced by these th two cells
and the eosinophils themselves are
actually causing the cell damage now
while we're talking about the two
subsets of cd4 cells CH 1 and 2 it's
useful to point out that the balance of
the two is really important for
determining the outcome and of infection
so an example is a vaccine that was
produced for RS virus so this is a
really important infection and we need
to be able to prevent it and so far our
old vaccines have failed there was one
made many
years ago now so the basis for this is
that if you get infected and survived
then you're protected against subsequent
lethal disease so that means the vaccine
might work a formalin inactivated
vaccine was developed a number of years
ago it didn't it didn't elicit a th1
response which is what virus infect
infection elicits it elicited a th2
response so remember the cd4 cells can
go either way depending on what the
dendritic cells are telling them in the
livers in the lymph node but the vaccine
is apparently not telling them the same
thing that the virus live virus
infection is now these children could
still be infected so they did a vaccine
trial with these children they got
infected and many of them got more
severe disease with a lot of eosinophils
in the lung remember in the mouse
experiment the eosinophils seemed to be
causing pathology so they had an
imbalanced cd4 response by the vaccine
and just last year was determined that
by formalin and activating the vaccine
you treat the virus with formalin at
cross-links the proteins makes the virus
not infectious
this made it a bad stimulator of a
toll-like receptor so one of the TLRs
recognizes the virus proteins initially
and you get a very good innate response
which then helps get high affinity
antibodies remember the innate and
adaptive responses for length the innate
response makes cytokines that helps
mature a very good immune response
antibody response
well this formalin treatment wrecked the
ability of the virus to make a good TLR
response so the results are low affinity
antibodies produced and these could not
neutralize infection in these kids so it
shows you that the innate response is
really important for getting good
antibody production yes did you have a
question
right right so that's what people are
doing trying to figure out how to
formulate the vaccine so that you get a
proper th1 response so we didn't
actually know this now we know the
reason for that is that we have a poor
TLR stimulation so we can try and make
an antigen that does that properly yeah
another example of an imbalanced
immunopathology cool response is
systemic inflammatory response syndrome
so if you're infected by a virus and
your immune system isn't controlling it
you start to get a lot of virus
replication early on if you're an 8
system can't control it
remember your adaptive defenses become
mobilized you get a global response so
it because from local response to a
global response you have lots of
antibodies and cell mediated immunity
many cytokines produced if this happens
really quickly and it can happen very
quickly or if the response is not
proportional you can get a large-scale
release of cytokines and stress
mediators the connect these can actually
kill you
so it's look it's sort of an
overreaction to the infection something
is imbalanced normally we have checks to
our immune responses that balance the
responses there are cytokines that
antagonize the positive action of other
cytokines but that can go awry sometimes
and then you get this a systemic
inflammatory response this happens often
when it's the first infection of a host
with the virus or say it's a zoonotic
infection where you get a infection from
an animal Ebola and Marburg viruses are
examples they go from animals into
people they don't typically spread from
person to person except in hospitals but
normally when there's an outbreak it's a
fresh outbreak from an animal and so
that's that's sort of an example of an
infection where the virus is not
co-evolved with the host so we also call
this a cytokine storm you get a lot of
cytokines produced in this
to be lethal to the host and some people
believe it might have been responsible
for the extreme lethality of the 1918
influenza pandemic where many many
millions of people died but it's very
difficult to prove at this point other
pathogens can do the same thing you may
have heard of toxic shock syndrome or
toxic sepsis these are bacteria
bacterial infections can have the same
effect they can overwhelm your system
you have an enormous response of
cytokine production a cytokine storm and
it can be lethal so that's systemic
inflammatory response syndrome here's
another example of how the immune
response can be pathological this is
West Nile virus encephalitis so this is
a virus borne by mosquitoes recently
introduced into the u.s. in a fraction
of people who are infected the virus
goes into your brain and causes an
infection of the brain matter itself
that's called encephalitis tlr3 seems to
be playing a role in the ability of the
virus to get into the brain so if you
take away the gene for tlr3 toll-like
receptor 3 which recognizes the viral
RNA as foreign you take away the tlr3
gene and mice they are more resistant to
infection
they make fewer cytokines because tlr3
of course is the sensor that says AHA
here's a virus RNA let's make cytokines
and get this immune response going one
of the cytokines that would be produced
is TNF alpha TNF alpha is known to
compromise the blood-brain barrier
remember there is a barrier between the
CNS circulation and the tissue proper
and that barrier can be compromised by
cytokines like TNF alpha so if you take
away TNF by taking away tlr3 the mice
get less lethal infection so here are
some pictures of mouse brains that shows
this and what what is done in these
experiments is actually to inject the
mice with a dye and this dye can get
into the brain of wild-type mice so you
infect mice with West
virus and then you inject also a dye and
the dye by day three gets into the brain
you can see the coloring the blue color
of the brain but look if you do the same
experiment in a tlr3 knockout Mouse you
infect you infect them with virus and
die
the the dye takes much longer to get in
the brain and it's much less so these
are mice now that are surviving have
have less severe encephalitis and it
looks like tlr3 is affecting the
permeability of the CNS via TNF alpha
and on the right are some controls the
interesting one here is that you can
inject the synthetic double-stranded RNA
called poly IC just by itself into mice
infected with I'm sorry that you just
inject the double-stranded RNA into mice
this recognizes TLR is recognized by
tlr3 so that those mice take up dye very
readily that within 12 hours but the
knockout mice you see don't because they
can't recognize the double-stranded RNA
because they have no tlr3 so there's no
dye going into the brain so an example
of how an innate response can cause
immunopathology dengue fever is an
example of the role of B cells in
immunopathology so we've gone through
all the cells the T cells now here's an
example of B cells in other words
antibody production and immunopathology
so dengue is a Flavie virus spread by
80s Egyptian is ciose right there and
this this infection is endemic in many
parts of the world billions of people
are at risk last year it actually were
actually a few cases in Florida and the
keys and actually spread from person to
person
which suggests that it may be entering
the US as well they're about 50 million
infections a year globally if Jim itch
makes it second only to malaria
among the insect borne diseases it's the
most common mosquito-borne viral disease
dengue so dengue is an evolving
infection before 1981 in the South in
Central America's really wasn't a
problem
but from here's the difference after
1981 you can see it spread throughout
and a good reason for this is that is
the used tire trade we use tires here in
the US when we wear them out they get
shipped overseas and big container ships
and tires fill with water and the
mosquitoes breed in them so these tire
container ships have spread 80s a jiffy
all over the world and this has been a
consequence to dengue spread has spread
infection so here are all the in yellow
the areas that have the vector and and
the red ones that were the vector in the
mosquito overlap so you can see the
portions of the Gulf of the globe where
it is endemic so this is a problem
because of what happens after you get
one infection so the primary infection
is usually asymptomatic but you may get
your standard symptoms of virus
infection you may have a fever and
severe headache back and limb pain and
rash it can have severe aches and pains
in the bones and the other name for this
infection is breakbone fever so it can
be painful but you usually recover in
seven to ten days in one in 14,000 of
these primary infections you get a
syndrome called dengue having
hemorrhagic fever which is
life-threatening and this is when you
are hemorrhaging your capillaries are
leaking fluids and blood and it can kill
you you saw so much internal bleeding
that patients develop shock syndrome
which is frequently fatal now if you
survive the first infection most of the
time you do you make antibodies to the
virus you have a memory response of
course but there are four different
serotypes of the virus and if you're
infected with one you're not protected
against the other three serotypes and
that's where the problem lies
so these non protective antibodies can
enhance the infection of monocytes with
another sera type of virus so let's say
you are infected with sera type one you
recover and then a few months later
you're infected with dengue two or three
you make a memory response to dengue
type one those antibodies will bind
dengue type - but they won't block it's
in
affection of cells and antibodies you
know have an FC portion and that can
attach to monocytes and macrophages they
have receptors and that lets the virus
get into these cells very efficiently
replicating them kill them and then they
all release cytokines and you get this
hemorrhagic fever syndrome so the
affected macrophages release cytokines
and those caused the severe symptoms so
the incidence of hemorrhagic fever and
shock syndrome is one in ninety and one
in fifty after your second infection so
this is a big problem because this is
often fatal so that's why dengue is a
big issue because we have so many
primary infections right now
so here's a schematic of what is going
on here here's a macrophage here in
yellow and it is
here's dengue virus or the little black
particles here and they can be coated by
antibodies that won't block their
infectivity if these antibodies were
against the same sera type those viruses
would not be able to infect cells but if
they're the wrong sera type they will
let the virus get into macrophages by FC
receptors those are these blue molecules
here macrophages get infected then they
start releasing cytokines like TNF alpha
which makes your your capillaries
permeable it activates complement so you
get plasma leakage and then you have of
course the macrophage is being attacked
by CTLs and that releasing even more
cytokines so you have this is a theory
and there's some evidence for this in
mice but it seems to make some sense so
there's a lot of effort to make a dengue
vaccine at the moment as a consequence
another form of immunopathology is the
deposition of immune complexes so when
you get a lot of virus multiplication
you know you have a good antibody
response within a few weeks you in in
certain areas you can get formation of
virus antibody complexes and these are
not cleared by your reticuloendothelial
system they circulate in the blood and
so basically you have circulating virus
receptor antibodies if they're not
cleared they can clog
shoes that have very fine capillaries
one of those is the kidney so here's a
diagram of the capillary in a glimmer
and a kidney glomerulus and these immune
deposits are shown here in red they can
clog these interstitial spaces and
eventually the fluid cannot leave the
capillary area and it swells and you get
you get kidney disease or glomerular
nephritis and this can happen in any
area with small capillaries you can get
vasculitis and glomerulonephritis and
people who have had this happen in their
brains end up having CNS symptoms like
mental confusion so immune complex
disease can be a problem and again this
is immunopathology it's the body
responding but something has gone awry
the other day we talked about these free
radicals that can cause cell injury
nitric oxide which is made by the
interferon inducible nitric oxide
synthase and that can cause cell damage
remember macrophages and monocytes
typically or NK cells typically go to
the infected monolayers reduce release
these radicals and they can kill the
cells and that can cause cell damage so
superoxide and nitric oxide are made
during inflammation and low
concentrations have a protective effect
because they remove the infected cells
but higher concentrations cause tissue
damage then as I said I I believe I said
this last time you can make mice that
lack this enzyme and show that they have
less pathology in response to certain
virus infections a couple of other ways
that the virus interacts with the host
and interesting ways one of them is
virus induced autoimmunity
so autoimmune disease is when you make
an immune response against your host
your own tissues there are many ways
that this happens but it also happens
during virus infection and in particular
virus infections in laboratory animals
have been demonstrated clearly to
trigger autoimmune responses you infect
an animal the animal makes antibodies to
the virus and some of those react with
the animals tissues whether this is true
in humans or not it's still up in the
air as far as I can tell
how does this work so there are a couple
of mechanisms that we'll talk about one
is the virus might replicate in a site
that is normally sequestered so the it's
not recognized by the immune response
but the consequence of virus
multiplication there is that antigens
are released which are not normally
recognized as self those are now exposed
and you get an autoimmune response so
that's one mechanism shown in animals
virus replication as you know leads to
the production of cytokines or
complement and these activate proteases
that can unmask normally hidden self
antigens and that ends up making an
antibody response against the self
antigen then the third mechanism is what
is called molecular mimicry so those
first two involve exposure by virus
infection of self antigens the third one
is something in common between the virus
and and our host proteins so here we
have a situation where viral and host
proteins share antigenic determinants so
you get infection you get an immune
response against the virus and some of
those antibodies react against you as
well now if you take all the proteins
encoded by us and you compare them to
all the viral proteins you're bound to
get something similar especially if you
look at an epitope which is short about
10 amino acids or so so there are a lot
of common sequences and it's not clear
whether this is actually a problem in
people you can show this experimentally
in a variety of ways but again there's
no clear evidence in people so here's
some example of epitopes the short amino
acid sequence is shared between virus
proteins and host proteins here's capsid
protein of polio and a sequence from the
acetylcholine receptor now you can make
these peptides you can make antibodies
against them and show that the
antibodies will cross react that's what
this means here but it's never been
shown that in people you're making
antibodies against your acetylcholine
receptor if you're infected with polio
and again you have examples here
papilloma virus and insulin receptor
rabies and insulin receptor HIV and
immunoglobulin sequence and measles and
cortical troph and so you know some
cases these are pretty good homologies
but whether this is actually an issues
is not really clear
another effective virus infection is
immunosuppression and that means that
some virus infection have a global
effect on reducing immune responses
mechanisms involve the virus replicating
in some immune cell that will do immuno
suppression if you get infected as a
fetus you typically get tolerant to the
virus and then that can immunosuppressed
as you age the virus infection can can
mess with cytokines or signaling that
are that's involved in cytokine
production that can cause immuno
suppression and even these virus
scepters and viral kinds the evasion
that's done by them is a form of
immunosuppression here's an experiment
that illustrates what we're talking
about so here what was done was to take
an animal and actually I think this is a
human with measles so they give a tine
test a tuberculin tine test to these
individuals and if they're uninfected
you get a certain amount of in duration
the raising of the of the swelling the
delayed type hypersensitivity and then a
child who has measles if you give them a
timed test initially they have no they
have no in duration from the TB test so
this is weeks after the rash of measles
appears so you can see very early on the
delayed type hypersensitivity to the
tuberculin antigen is suppressed by
measles and then eventually as the
measles infection wanes then you get a a
reaction so an example of
immunosuppression by measles virus so
here are some examples measles is a big
one it infects monocytes and thymic
epithelial cells causes reduced delayed
type hypersensitivity as I just showed
you and you get enhanced infections with
other microbes when you have measles
rubella the same thing in facts lymphoid
cells the consequence here is that you
get a
just and rubella infection so you can't
clear it and of course HIV probably the
best-known immunosuppressed the virus
infects cd4 positive T cells the helper
T cells that you need for the for the
maturation of all those antibody and CTL
responses so as a consequence you get
opportunistic infections and cancer and
that's what ends up killing you measles
virus immunosuppression the dendritic
cells and monocytes actually get
infected so when that happens
remember the dendritic cells are
important for presenting the viral
antigens to Thank You T cells in the
lymph node so when measles infects them
that ability is compromised so the the
lymph nodes can never be informed
properly that there's an infection going
on in addition and measles infected
people your T lymphocytes are decreased
by 50% and that's the consequence of not
being educated in the lymph node you
also get aberrant cytokine responses you
get a skewing of the th response from th
one to th two because you get different
cytokines that are produced and we're
going to end up with a few a little
discussion on what makes you susceptible
to disease so we've talked about
specific ways about we've talked about
virulence and what regulates it we've
talked about immunopathology quite a bit
we're gonna end up talking about
susceptibility the you would like to
know of course what human genes regulate
susceptibility this is this this work
starts in animal models the MX gene
which we talked about the other day
determines the susceptibility of mice to
influenza virus there's also an FLV gene
in mice that determines susceptibility
to Flavie viruses like West Nile virus
this gene encodes an interferon
stimulated protein the to five prime
time I'll ago a synthetase unfortunately
neither of these play any role in human
infections so we can't learn running
much from that here's an effect of the
FLV gene on susceptibility we have two
strains of mice
that are either susceptible to infection
you infect them and you see virus
multiplication very nicely in the
susceptible strain the resistant strain
very little virus production the
susceptible strain has a mutation in the
FLV gene that makes it inactive
basically in the FLV gene encoding two
five five prime alla goya synthesis is
an important antiviral protein human
determinants of susceptibility not easy
to find most of them encode components
of the innate system ccr5 a chemokine
receptor protects against HIV so there
are many people that have a natural
deletion in ccr5 and they are resistant
to HIV and that apparently is fine you
don't need to have ccr5 but these
individuals also seem to be more
susceptible to West Nile virus infection
mutations in toll-like receptor 3 and a
second protein called uncle 93 B which
is needed for tlr3 signaling predispose
people to herpes simplex so you can look
in people now we can sequence genomes
and look at mutations associated with
susceptibility and this is one of the
more recent one that has come out herpes
encephalitis herpes encephalitis yes
herpes simplex encephalitis yeah viral
encephalitis is infection of the pia the
brain matter with a virus and meningitis
is is an infection of the meninges right
so it can as far as viruses go there are
other things that can cause encephalitis
but when we talk about viral
encephalitis were talking about
replication in the cells that comprise
the brain matter okay MHC class 1 and 2
molecules have also been associated with
resistance to infection these of course
present antigens to lymphocytes and it's
been shown that certain MHCs are simply
better at recognizing certain peptides
as foreign than others so for example
HIV resistance to HIV
and a number of people tracks with a
certain MHC molecule so here's an
example of this in mice two different
strains of mice with two different MHC
molecules one very susceptible and one
quite resistance and as I said this
tracks with people in terms of HIV
infection as well age is a determinant
of susceptibility very young and very
old people are typically the most
susceptible to infection we believe that
is in the young people the immune
response is immature but that can
sometimes help you you have less
immunopathology for example in infection
of mice with lymphocytic Koryo
meningitis virus is lethal in adults but
infant mice survive remember this is a
cd8 mediated lethality an infant my
simply don't have well-developed cd8
cells the susceptibility increased
susceptibility of older people is
multifactorial SE elastic alveoli in the
lungs for example weaker respiratory
muscles diminished cost reflexes all
makes older people more susceptible to
respiratory infections like influenza so
these are just two experiments looking
at the susceptibility of rats to West
Nile virus infection and you can see
this is age specific ld50 titer so this
is increasing age and this is the amount
of virus you need to kill 50 percent of
the animals so at a very young age you
need a lot of virus to kill half the
animals and you need less as you get
older and the same goes for age specific
replication in the brain three months of
age not very much replication but as you
age you have more replication sorry 1.5
days the most replication 16 days
slightly less than three months no
replication this is an epidemic in the
Faroe Islands which are north of the UK
in 1846 and you can see the high
mortality in the less than one age group
and the greater than 70 age groups
everyone in between
pretty low mortality but the very young
and the very old particularly
susceptible what is this all about well
we have one specific mechanism in mice
infected with sin Bucyrus if you infect
very young mice they get brain
infections but as the mice get older
they're resistant to brain lethal
infection the reason is this protein
called bcl-2 which is anti-apoptotic as
mice age there's more bcl-2 produced and
that protects the mice against apoptosis
induced by infection there are
exceptions to this very young very old
rule okay for example respiratory
syncytial virus causes severe infections
in infants but doesn't do anything in
older people and this is probably
because the immune response of the older
people is matured in 1918 the flu
pandemic was lethal for the very young
and the very old that's consistent with
what we've said but also for adults
young adults 18 to 30 years old and we
don't know why that is many other
infections are milder at young ages
rather than old ones polio for example
is very mild at a young age
we don't really understand that it could
be that there's a balance of protective
and pathogenic responses so maybe when
you're young you don't make as many
immuno pathological responses to
infection and so some of these
infections are less severe this is a
graph showing this unusual mortality in
1918 for influenza
so here's flu in the u.s. from 1911 to
1915 the young and the old are the most
susceptible this is death rate according
to age and in 1918 there was this
unusual spike in the middle in addition
to the young and old we still don't
understand why that is and here's an
example another example of increasing
mortality just in old age this is West
Nile virus mortality in Israel in 2000
the very young were fine but here the
decade of life not only the incidence of
severe disease but mortality was
specific to the older individuals so
again it
not simply the case that the very young
and the very old are always more
susceptible other determinants gender
males are slightly more susceptible
pregnant women in particular highly
susceptible to infection with a number
of viruses and you may remember that
when pandemic influenza merged in 2009
pregnant women seemed to be dying at a
faster rate than others malnutrition
also increases susceptibility because of
its effects on the immune response and
this is why measles is 300 times more
lethal in developing countries because
of malnutrition can be a death sentence
in those countries
cigarette smoking increases
susceptibility to respiratory infection
is no question air pollution as well and
stress stress causes increased
susceptibility but remember stress
spelled backwards is desserts so when
you get stressed have dessert and you
won't get a virus infection okay so next
week there's no class of course we have
the following week and exam on Wednesday
so this weekend I will post some
practice questions okay so check the
website or course works I will also post
a quiz on Sunday so you can keep up
practicing wherever you are okay so
check that out and I will have office
hours probably asked there we'll do a
review she'll contact you next week but
I will have office hours next week I
will post them one day next week so if
you have any questions you can come see
me
you